the entertainment world was stunned on
Saturday by the death of sitcom star
Matthew Perry the actor who played
Chandler Bing and friends died on
Saturday October 28th 2023 at the age of
54 in addition to his work on Friends
Perry also had notable roles in films
like the whole nine yards and 17 again
and series like The Odd Couple Mr
Sunshine and go on following the reports
of Perry's passing several stars from
across the industry began sharing their
condolences and their memories of Perry
among those Stars a Star Trek actor
George teay who tweeted his condolences
for Perry's family teay wrote what a
tragic piece of news to read my heart
goes out to his loved ones and longtime
castmates OA Jackson Jr also tweeted
about his sadness at the news of Perry's
death writing quote no meanwhile Teen
Wolf and Yellowstone star Ian Bowen
tweeted holy Matthew Perry noing
way the news of Perry's death shocked
Hollywood on Saturday and celebrities
from outside the world of Hollywood were
also paying tribute to the man who made
Chandler Bing a house old name WWE
legend Mick Foley tweeted about Perry
expressing his condolences for the Stars
friends and family and praising his work
on Friends fley tweeted I'm really so
sorry to hear of the death of actor
Matthew Perry I'm such a big fan of
friends I've been wearing a friend shirt
the past two days and Perry's Chandler
Bing character was the one I identified
with most Perry's former co-stars also
tweeted their memories of the star this
includes Sterling Knight who co-starred
with Perry in 17 Again Knight tweeted
his memories of working with Perry
including sharing a photo of the two on
the red carpet along with their other
co-stars from the film Knight tweeted I
was so lucky to be in this photo and
more lucky still to have been a part of
such an amazing cast my first big job
everyone was so kind and I made an utter
ass of myself in front of my sitcom hero
Matthew Perry he was kind genuine
offered advice and inspired confidence
I'll always be a little bummed that we
never got to play tennis but Heaven must
have needed some sarcasm and he was the
best as the news of Matthew Perry's
death continued to spread across the
globe more tributes poured in for the
Emmy nominated friend star comedian and
filmmaker Tom Green praised the friends
actor and noted that the two hail from
the same city Ottawa green expressed his
condolences and what Perry stardom meant
for the duo Hometown Greene tweeted
shocked and saddened to just hear about
the passing of Matthew Perry in a tragic
drowning he's one of the many talented
and incredible success stories from my
hometown of Ottawa Canada rest in peace
Matthew Nancy Sinatra also tweeted her
sadness at the news of Perry's passing
writing quote thanks for being you
Sinatra also encouraged her followers to
read Perry's book friends lovers and the
big terrible thing as Sinatra noted if
you loved Matthew Perry as I did read
his book you will learn a lot about him
meanwhile another '90s television star
also paid tribute to Perry Jason
Alexander who played George castanza on
Seinfeld tweeted his morning at the news
of Perry's death writing what a
wonderful and unique talent he will long
be remembered and cherished for the gift
of his work and sorely missed by so so
many